[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars this is
the boys underground where we break down
amazon's grittiest darkest
disgustingness live-action superhero
show with me today is marina mastros hi
uh episode 4 just dropped last night
not as bad
oh what were you gonna well last night
but
oh god the rush of this dang
episode not dropping until 5 00 a.m
pacific standard whatever what have you
either way i'm irritated by it
she was definitely up and i mean stayed
up and then got up early i only got up
early but she was like i'm up i'm
staying up late and i got up early i
couldn't do it and if you guys are
watching you're like jessica looks
really tired today it's like yeah
because i've been up since two in the
morning
bezos did this stuff he did this to the
and the thing is i don't know why i keep
relying on him knowing that he's bad and
wrong yeah
true i literally it was i'm sure that
the people watching also had to endure
the same exact thing twitter was mad
twitter was pissed so we're going to
bring you an episode today jam-packed
yep uh i watched it in some manner
if it was legal or not but episode 4
does give us everything we really didn't
want which is more homelander success
they really were like yeah give them
give them the give them the trophy give
them what he wants
oh god just teeter it like this tip the
scales i after watching this episode i
immediately was like he needs to die i
was like he's gone three seasons yeah
he's got in the first second and really
please just kill him really and that's
why i think the show is so good is
because i'm like
even if he doesn't die i'm not like
upset with the show the writing yeah no
it's really like very satisfying and
here's what you know it was good is like
i was up at six which is not as early as
you but i was still like i'm not even
mad like i'm not mad yeah i'm not i
wasn't yeah it was i actually really
enjoyed this episode yeah yeah i really
enjoyed this episode so let's get into
our recap
our recap yes okay so
episode 4 stan edgar teams up with
victoria newman his adopted daughter and
director of fbsa to go after homelander
despite her concerns and fears
surrounding this plan and her daughter
zoe she accepts
she later changes her mind and works in
tandem with homelander because in
exchange for helping homelander newman
ask for a vial of compound v so she
could turn her daughter into a soup like
herself thus protecting her life which
is like i
okay it's a good idea i get it i get it
yeah but oh my that scene was so sad i
know that scene was a horrible at first
i didn't um i was like
i was just like not like i thought it i
it's because she said something and i
think i missed the i missed the catch
where she was like my daughter can't rip
out my spine um i thought she said my
daughter can rip out my spine so i was
like oh so her daughter is already a
soup and then when she injected her with
compound v i was like she's making her
super suit is she giving her the she's
making a double soup yeah look at her
double soup calm down calm down that's
why i could give her a heart attack
but it was yeah yeah you're right i
think i missed that too but that's good
a good catch uh so starlight joins maeve
in taking down homelander supersonic
joins oh god so sad and what we hoped
was a train but a train after being made
a fool of by the deep if they fight
they're going to fight in a hallway and
then eventually
a train outs the plan to take down
homelander to homelander
uh to get on to get on his good side i
guess which is like snitch move come on
stupid idiot yeah
what side is a good side of homeland
yeah he's still gonna use you he also
still hates you he thinks you can't run
he calls you he makes fun of your size
and you haven't yeah exactly yeah it's
snark a train is all honestly fool as a
fool and an idiot and i loved him and i
gave him a chance after that stupid
outfit he made
what is it what is this his brain is
being by stupid or whatever yeah yeah
his brain is being by stupid his brain
is being [ __ ] by
god oh man okay so butcher and the boys
reach out to nina the russian crime boss
to get details on the weapon that killed
soldier boy and they come to an
agreement that involves chemical killing
a russian crime leader in exchange for
the address to the lab where they're
keeping a soup killing weapon so butcher
takes his v again and he's interrupted
by huey who is like please he literally
begs to try it butcher refuses and then
butcher takes out every russian guard
with kimiko too yeah yeah
using his superpowers and right when mm
is about to be killed hughie jumps in
teleporting superhuman fast right
through his clothes and pushes the hole
right through the guard and because he
stole some compound b from butcher's
bundle and the whole gang is like very
disappointed in him way more
disappointed in healy than in butcher
because they know he's already a dick so
they're like
they were like parents like emma was
like i'm disappointed that scene when mm
said that i was like it hurts me yeah
like it hurts more it hurts more and he
was very disappointed yeah and chemicals
like i i know anyone's saying anything i
was like yeah
that's how i'd react she's like you let
me down uh so they don't end up finding
the weapon but they indeed find soldier
boy in a cryo freezer who implodes
injuring chemical who isn't healing
instantly right yes homelander later
confronts starlight about her plan to
topple him and in a horrific scene it
shows her supersonics ripped off face
and limbs
so is it lesson learned i mean basically
downlinder right
and they say it every episode that
episode where he was like yeah you can
take away everything that i love and
i'll just kill everybody yeah like once
you do that i'm gonna murder everyone
and then here he was like why don't you
get it i am above you like there is
nothing you can do to stop me and why
would you try like if you step one more
inch i'm going to have to actually hurt
people that you like oh my god
oh okay okay guys i want to get into
this uh this episode is so heavy but of
course a word from our sponsors not our
sponsors just us uh be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com where we currently
have two latest obsession shirts that's
right two you can grab the obi-wan
kenobi uh themed shirt empire's most
wanted or miss marvel's themed shirt
cosmic daydream both shirts are limited
edition and won't last long and when you
purchase the latest obsession shirt you
unlock the ability
to get a shout out a custom shout out on
either our obi-wan kenobi show or the
miss marvel after show our inside marvel
shows uh and your name will also be said
at the bottom of the screen so check out
all of our awesome merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and maybe you'll get a shirt with my
face on it i don't think it exists yet
but maybe maybe one day so
now that we get back into episode four
yeah let's get into this missable
details because there's so much and it's
also like this episode actually favors
the comics so much oh great it's so much
and i can't wait uh hopefully we can get
the assets to put it up in here so of
course the first one that we have to
acknowledge is the a train uh
kendall jenner oh my god the 2012 so
satisfying honestly what is it i i hate
i i don't like like being embarrassed
for people oh that's why i can't fast
forward the show because i talk about
the show to you guys every friday it's i
mean i totally understand the
perspective it's anytime people make fun
of like people who kind of deserve to
make get made fun of i'm like
that's true i should
i should have went in with that
understanding of being like god he needs
to be taken down a notch just roast her
rose it's kendall right yeah yeah
stupid pepsi
that commercial was roast them get them
that was awful uh we also have the title
episode is called
uh five year plan gloria's five-year
plan comes from volume two in the comics
um which the boys do travel to russia as
you can see from all the graffiti russia
really despises the american superheroes
um and
they only kind of care about soldier boy
which understandably because they're
harboring soldier boy right now as
like a a bomb
whatever he shoots out of his chest
which we'll get into we will definitely
talk about it uh the first this is also
the first meeting of the seven since
season one episode one oh yeah which is
insane to me we are on three seasons and
the seven have never been a full seven
but also haven't had a team meeting
because they all hate each other that's
so oh wow but it was to like have some
taco salads though it was yeah you have
to get everybody together for that
as a mexican-american i was like yeah
yeah it was
straight up out of that trump tweet
where he was like yes happy cinco de
mayo i love taco salads i was like oh
god get em oh god
okay so oh god
[Laughter]
volume 12 issue 72 of the comics when
bot executive james stillwell is
bitterly disappointed by the new
superhero team being rolled out called
true he stands at a window and he
literally is like being very mean to
homelander he calls him a bad product
and they even copy the same line of the
82 over 63.
82 over 65. i can't but there's though
that scene in that comic is like
mimicked uh shot for shot in the show
yeah which is really great all right
it's beautiful go look it up i think
that's great hopefully we will have an
asset i'll bring an asset uh jamie the
hamster is actually
real in the comics uh but the
unfortunate thing about jamie the
hamster is he
um
there's a soup called blarney
who is a racist and has the powers of a
chicken
what's the powers of a chicken jessica i
don't know i can't tell you but he has
the powers of a chicken
and he's actually maeve's son uh but he
also shoves the hamster up his ass uh in
the comics and uh when he went i need to
start reading the game huey it's
actually also the first person that
hewey kills in the comics and he punches
a hole directly through his abdomen wow
okay so reference yeah just like the
same we see today except we're just not
putting blarney there's also yeah who
needs a chicken racist um yeah we did
season two uh nazi stuff yeah we don't
need any more nazis this time uh but
those were just like these missile
details that are this this episode is
very close tied to the comics just for
scenes so let's get into the actual big
questions or hard theories
i want to know how did nina know where
the lab was she clearly is in the loop
about everything also she's not in
russia currently so the fact that she
was like
i can easily tell you where the weapon
is right like was it too easy well i
mean yes it's a show it's written but
think about this though like crime lords
who get imprisoned they still run things
from prison that is true so even if
you're in another country it's kind of
like
you know that's true not the exact same
thing as prison but you're separated and
people still run entire stuff as long as
you have a cell phone that's okay what
she does yeah she does i was holding on
to like when we talked about in the last
boys underground that she was basically
staging a coup with the government but
like with vaught and i was like maybe
she wanted them to get him yeah because
then she can try to stop him maybe
that's the suit because in the comics
they had like bombs put into all their
heads and then exploded and vaught was
like see we saved russia so it's like
maybe she's trying to do that with um
soldier boy oh yeah um because i'm like
oh but also i'm also like did you did
she know that the soldier boy was there
and not the weapon
well okay i don't know if you remember
this last time uh and if this is where
we get into it or not but remember how
last time i was like what if what if
soldier boy like is the weapon
because and i was thinking about this as
i was watching i was like
if they have developed you know how they
have like biological weapons it's like
what if they literally couldn't deploy
it without it being in a pr
no that says let's already let's i yes
100 i ride for this theory it actually
is very true because even if it's like
even if um he they did have a weapon and
they use it on soldier boy they're
probably like well he existed and he
said he's still like is alive so maybe
we just experiment on him and keep him
as our weapon right now yeah like i he
is
okay our next our next one because this
ties
what super powers does soulja boy now
have because these are new and that's
i'm like he clearly can take away other
superpowers from soups yeah so it's like
uh
the first one is generating some sort of
blast right yes
but in the process of that because i i
don't know if you agree with this i
don't think he was aiming for frenchie i
don't think he was aiming for chemical i
think he was just aiming for the wall
honestly actually i think he just
imagine if you will you're in cryostasis
frozen okay for 36 years
and then you come out and you had a you
had a superpower absorbed into you yeah
that's different than your normal
strength speed and just mercenary skills
don't you think that'd be the first
thing unleashed as soon as you're taken
out what if you're just trying to get
rid of it because you're right like what
if it was all just like
also it's like since it's been 36 years
maybe that was the biggest blast he
could do maybe now it's gonna be weaker
oh yeah like i i i do believe that he is
now the weapon
he i what i really want to know is is he
does it temporarily take your powers
away yeah because that would be great
for kymco she doesn't want to have her
power she doesn't want to be a gun but
then also
she will probably die
she has right now and also it's does it
is it just that it
that that weapon or that blast is immune
to
v
and the powers like it doesn't actually
remove her powers it's just that that
blast
isn't affected by powers if you don't
you know what i'm saying like um if if
if soldier boy shoots homelander yes
it's not that homelander after that
point
neglects to have any powers like he
loses his vis his fire vision he can't
fly anymore it's just that if you get
hit by it your superpowers don't save
you from it if that makes i think so i
think yeah i think that's correct i
think it's like once that that thing
hits you it's like you it penetrates
your powers yeah i just think it's it
keeps your powers dormant for a minute
and okay that minute can kill you okay
but and i think that's uh
where they're gonna go with this yeah my
also my biggest concern is like you got
to like treat him like a vampire you got
to burn his body because what happens
when he regenerates right like a family
what is he what if he's rejected he's
homeless so it's like what if he like
just like immediately is like whoop and
comes back normal you guys got to burn
his body
honestly it's so funny honestly they'd
probably still burn his body regardless
does he have a regenerative powers in
the comics do you remember
i assume he does uh i don't think
they've shown him having regenerative
powers i think he's in the show because
he never gets hit no well or like he's
immune to basically everything but i
don't
think he has regenerative powers that
they've shown and then the show in the
show yeah i haven't
i'm trying to think if he ever got like
actually injured because that's the
whole thing is he's he's the he's the
number one yeah he'll he'll just speed
away he hears you before you hear him
he knows good question that's
interesting oh you know what other sorry
uh
soldier boy does have one other
superpower
and it is having a teeny tiny gym inside
his cell because he came out of that
looking
whoo
jensen echols said you know jacked he
said you know what we got a nude scene
i'm gonna jack myself like i'm gonna not
jerk myself i'm gonna i'm gonna get so
beefed up yeah he
straight up in an interview he was like
they made a joke where he came on set
and they were like you didn't have to
get all buffed your outfit has muscles
put into it and he felt stupid and then
we have this scene where i'm like no
this boy that was a smart move we saw
huey's little butt and i was like that's
just a little butt yeah and i saw jensen
echoes but yeah i said oh that's
that man has earned his paycheck he did
he has done some extra work homework on
the side
so clearly there was a teeny tiny gym in
that little compartment and he was like
or maybe being cryogenic frozen just
like makes you really strong your
muscles are constantly working yeah so i
i brought up last week during the boys
underground that i thought that maybe
because of the outfit he's in that it
was like the 90s when um
whatchamacallit's fam mother's milk's
family died so
he clearly is just wearing this
tracksuit that we see him in the trailer
because he got it from someone in russia
so there goes that yeah there goes my
theory but also i think it's very funny
it is very funny you just got a russian
track suit what do you do
um okay and then oh following
what does stan edgar leaving vaught mean
for vaude
like
oh my gosh well who's next in line
actually i mean it is actually because
i know right
they had that scene where ashley is
telling the
not fox executive
what to say and uh so she's in charge
right now which makes sense honestly
because uh she was the second the what
is it called like
she was like the personal assistant to
homelander and now that homeland is in
charge he probably was just like
actually runs everything because he
tells ashley what to do true so
but an answer to your question
catastrophic
failure as a company it's it's the thing
is which i loved about his stan edgar's
uh uh like monologue of just like
i was the one that like took the like
shots for you like i was the one
everything fell onto me every time you
messed up now it's gonna fall into you
yeah and he has
no idea how it is to run a company
period he horrible he's combative yeah
clearly hr would have a problem with
homelander and so having him run bought
yeah and he immediately was like that's
a place for superheroes and he's like no
remember when we just sold
pharmaceuticals like you guys still need
to make money somehow yeah and you're a
crazy racist psycho man yeah so it's
like they're going to fail it is going
to
be horrible yeah and it's all going to
fall on ashley oh my god well the fact
that like ashley is in charge is very
worrisome because she
i don't think i've seen a scene and i
could be wrong where she like
demonstrated herself to be extremely
competent like ever in the show like
ever so
the fact that she's in charge of this
company is like very worrying but here's
what i think is going to happen too
they're going to play place all the
blame on stan edgar he's going to go to
maybe jail temporarily or like but
although he has a team of lawyers too
i'm sure but when homelander takes over
his approval ratings are really high
right now so i think temporarily stock
prices go through the roof oh oh
that is true so the company thrives
like for a time
and then it starts tumbling down
after homeland messes up or something or
actually you know the scenes that i
think we haven't seen are the scenes
that like the rallies that are clearly
people support we had that weird scene
with mother milk's daughter's stepfather
where he leaned in put his beard down
during a uh homelanders speech about
being a crazy person so it's like we
still didn't see the audience we haven't
seen any of the civilians be like i'm
team homelander and once he's in control
of bot yeah he's gonna just kick
starlight to the side like he's still
gonna be like you're my main squeeze but
we're not co-captains anymore yeah yeah
it's just not they love me and i'm gonna
make sure it's me front line you guys
all behind me and they are falling in
the line yeah like after i mean
after victoria newman's thing i was like
great he's back he's back so now that
the seven is short a member oh poor it
took me a minute it took me a minute to
recognize who it was and then when i saw
his suit i was like he ripped out his
face
he pulled off his limbs i want to see
i'm a normal person
i want to see what he said to him yeah
like i feel so bad for that baby i know
he got he was warned like five times i
guess he didn't think that he was going
to get his face ripped off
[Applause]
his face is gone you guys so
where's his his family's gonna be like
where's the body i know and they can't
show you the body because it got ripped
off
so oh god it was almost as worse as when
they were in like it was like the first
season when ashley was like here's
another person of the seven and i think
they were uh were they blind
oh yeah and then he started and then he
like does his ninja stuff yeah and then
the homelander was just like i'm gonna
kill you yeah immediately clapped his
ears it insane like homeland is a menace
now that the seven is short another
member who's next we had so i i took a
look at the screen in this episode or in
the last episode where they had the
board of all the people that were on
american hero so they had moon shadow
and silver kincaid were the the bottom
two or not the bottom two the last two
it was them and super sonic and they
made it pretty clear they didn't want
brown people so i don't think either the
two women women specifically yeah brown
women specifically brown women
specifically uh perfect show for us to
be hosted right now um they didn't want
brown women specifically their problem
in their loss um also after seeing what
they did the supersonic
don't put them on there i don't want
them
ripped off so i know
they're probably not going to take them
but there were other people that were
also on there there was light speed that
was contested number four
i'm honestly just assuming probably is
also a fast person yeah um but number
five was critter who is a giant beast
man imagine um
uh the banjo playing monster in
powerpuff girls the pink one the that is
what critter is he's huge he's messy and
everyone's afraid of him because he's so
big and clumsy it's like having first
first avengers movie hulk
it's like having he's just a menace and
a mess but he was number five on the
list
so is it possible that we might go back
to american hero or do you think they're
gonna just
bring back
some
someone else
you know what i mean he homeliner might
use american hero to gain back favor
like things might start to slump and
then he might be like oh wait let's uh
get back on tv don't don't start not
liking me or i mean i'm trying to think
of like or you know what honestly he's
gonna start hand picking he is i'm i
think he's still holding on to victoria
newman i think because at first i was a
piece a piece of me was like i think he
might put her in charge of what because
oh he has her in her pocket yeah he
knows her weakness and
when he was like you want to blow up my
head go ahead try it because if you
don't i'm gonna kill you yeah um i was
like and that would be a good person for
him to like bring in because he'd be
like you're just as good as your dad
you're just not an [ __ ] like to
homelander but then i was like if not
bought maybe he'll ask her to be in the
seven and like force her to be out her
oh yeah he's definitely as a as a
student he's gonna out her for sure or
something's gonna happen with his her
daughter i don't think that's a good
idea giving her daughter
you vile the compound vegan how can i
get it she's terrified and also that's
what homelander has on her right because
like she could maybe defend herself but
she yeah that's the thing is like what
does she think she thinks homeland is
gonna send maeve after her it's like no
homelanders gonna come and no one can
stop him don't do this to your daughter
know um poor buddy but oh and then last
question last but not least
where does starlight go from oh
poor girl she first of all i'm waiting
for the guilt from
getting her little friend killed which
sucks i mean i'm a blamer obviously it's
homemade as well but she must feel yeah
i feel horrible so horrible and probably
she doesn't want to get close to anybody
anymore because that was just her friend
like literally just her friend so she
might actually break up with huey but
like actually break up with you because
they've had a back and forth but they're
gonna do it again like actually yeah i
think so too i think and also it's so
she doesn't want to put huey in in
harm's way yeah and huey being a doofus
is going to take compound v and think
teleporting is going to fight it's going
to help him play his own labor oh my god
i think it was a teleport because it
like it disappeared at first i thought
it was super speed yeah but he
disappeared and like jumped out of his
clothes jumped out of his clothes oh
yeah you're right okay yeah i thought it
was super speedy at first which i'm more
interested in yeah i mean all of them
take compound v and seen because i
thought they would all have homelanders
abilities but i was like oh it's nice to
see that they all have different
abilities it was very funny i did laugh
watching it because i was like of course
billy butcher gets like laser vision
super strength all that stuff the cool
thing he gets the home lender he gets
the home blender abilities and then huey
gets teleportation which is honestly a
very
useful i like it teleport
a very useful superpower he could
potentially teleport to russia and back
he could that is true get ahold of it
and also
don't be a hero huey you can run away
from homeland for a good portion of time
using that teleporting yeah this is what
i would do i'd be like oh
that's the only way you can get away
from him because no matter how fast you
can fly a run if you you can teleport
yourself to the other end
isn't god but he thinks he is and he
acts like it you cannot get away he
hears your heartbeat yeah he can smell
your blood
well what if like uh starlight breaks up
with hugh and then he's sad and then he
just teleports himself to like an island
alone
oh my god
and he's like it's fine and then but
then his powers were off so then he
stuck there oh my god i would cry
because
stop doing my boy like that i know stop
doing my boy
jack
exists happily in this universe please i
know he can't no one can no no but geez
louise and poor starlight she's just
[Music]
i think queen maeve is going to probably
die i have a feeling she's going to die
because she's going to try to go against
homeland homelander herself because
she's clearly like i have nothing else
to lose either like she doesn't have
elena anymore so it's like she's just
like i'm gonna go in and i'm like you
have a sword
i know i saw that too i was like girl
girl
he's got laser eyes you got a sword i'm
not trying to be that person yeah i'm
not trying to be that person great
training great great great strong woman
just
yeah just so you're bringing a line like
a line bringing a knife to a gunfight
yeah a knife to a gunfight or maybe like
more than one sword like a gun that
shoots swords or something just like
anything
that shoots nice
maybe you would probably do it oh god
okay now we have your segment oh yes the
kill count oh yeah my pride and joy okay
so uh we had to wait a little bit for
the kills to start coming in this
episode but it's very worth it so in
order of appearance okay uh kim and code
killed not one not two not three but
fours russian security guards and her
weapon of choice was a dildo
take that ted cruz
she was
the thing is
if you guys know dildos look here look
here you know dildos and you do and you
do and i you do i know you do nasty
nasty underground boy freaks uh they are
not easy to stab through someone's face
that's right so the fact is it was all
just force from chemical straight up
rambling through people the vibrator in
the neck i know and then it started
still going i was like okay turn it off
i was like
quality vibrator
still going it's still going still going
look at all that blood still oh my god
yes a special mention and it was a
starlight vibrator uh so special mention
of course so i'm gonna give i'm also
gonna give uh one to the blonde woman
who had obviously been sex trafficked by
this russian oligarch of some kind or
crime syndicate guy um because even
though kimiko doesn't stay dead
she was a dead shot
dead on aim i think there's going to be
something about that girl and i want to
actually hold on to it because that was
a dead like dead shot
it went boop clean it was the wolverine
scene of wolverine and shawn there and
then pushing it out yeah it was i was
like okay she's gonna do something she's
gonna do something don't give her
compound v she's she's gonna murder her
she's gonna go crazy
uh so she has one which is great so then
can we go snap the neck of a guard
during the fight to obtain or free or
find soldier boy jamie the hamster
crawled into the eye socket of a russian
guard which was very funny and butcher
absolutely annihilated three russian
guards when he souped up for the second
time then to save mm huey punched a
guard so fast that his dick came out
and last but not least and most
impressively of all homelander just
absolutely [ __ ] up alex uh killing him
as well so our kill counts are russian
woman one homelander one huey one jamie
the hamster one billy butcher three and
kimiko with six with a total of 12 for
the episode that's not that many deaths
it's not that many people the war
the war reenactment the war scene where
everyone was getting exploded but when
you kill someone with a dildo it counts
as two honestly it counts as two because
that's the dildo also lost to life that
day
in what episode are we going to be like
jamie the hamster one kill it's like
i know right and honestly arguably other
than the dildo scene worse death in the
episode that eyeball is gone
you guys that is this episode of the
boys underground uh thank you marie
thank you thank you
next time we will see how many people we
can kill with dildos uh new rockstar is
paying for it they're expensive uh
follow all of us follow marina marina
masteros follow new rockstars and new
rockstars follow me at lulu underscore
clemens follow us on our new tumblr
which i am the person in control of whoo
fun fun little thing there um and then
oh yeah make sure to check out our merch
at new rockstarsmerge.com
and make sure to join the new rockstars
discord server as long as you're over 18
you're free to join and that's it for
today yay we did it we did it and it
only took us until five in the morning
have a good day everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you